كل ما هوّ عربي، يسبب حساسية مفرطة لإريك زيمور…
فبالإضافة إلى قضية الأسماء العربية،
فإن اللغة العربية نفسها
يعتبرها لغة متناقضة مع العقلانية
مثلما ذهب إلى ذلك المؤرخ العنصري ارنست رينان في القرن التاسع عشر.
اللغة العربية اليوم حسب إريك زيمور هي مجرد عنصر ناقل للإنفصالية الإسلامية.
اللغة الخامسة الأكثر انتشارا في العالم
العربية هي اللغة الثالثة من حيث الإقتراض اللغوي للفرنسية
بعد الإنجليزية و الإيطالية.
كل هذا لا يعني شيئا لإريك زيمور،
لأنّه يجهل ان عدد الكلمات العربية في اللغة الفرنسية تزيد خمس مرات عن عدد الكلمات القلطية،
لغة "أسلافنا الغاليين"،
من مجموع ستين ألف كلمة تُشكّل النواة الرئيسية للغة الفرنسية هناك 500 كلمة عربية.
فقط عند فطور الصباح تستعملون اربع كلمات عربية؛
تتناولون طاسا من آلقهوة،
كلمتي طاس و(كافي) قهوة، كلمتين عربيتين،
سوف تضيفون (السكّر) لقهوتكم،
كلمة (سكّر) كلمة عربية،
ثمّ تتناولون un jus d'orange (عصير برتقال)
كلمة (أورنج) متأتية كذلك من كلمة "نارنج" العربية.
ويمكننا ان نسترسل في تعداد الكلمات؛
كلمة (جاسمين) الفرنسية هي كلمة ياسمين العربية،
كلمة (جيتار) الفرنسية متأتية من كلمة جيتارة العربية،
كلمة (كُوطُن) الفرنسية هي كلمة قطن العربية،
وتوجد كذلك عشرات الكلمات العلمية،
كلمة (آلجابر) الفرنسية هي كلمة الجبر العربية،
وكلمة (آلغوريتم) الفرنسية هي كلمة عربية مشتقة من اسم عالم الرياضيات محمد بن موسى الخوارزمي،
وكلمة (شيمي) chimie الفرنسية هي كلمة كيمياء العربية،
وعلامة الآروباز @
التي نستعملها جميعا في بريدنا الإلكتروني
هي مشتقة من كلمة "إرروبا" الإسبانية،
المشتقة بدورها من كلمة "الربع" العربية
وهي وحدة قياس قديمة.
الكاتب الكبير ابن ميمون،
الذي يُعتبر في التراث اليهودي النبي موسى الثاني،
والذي كان طبيبا لصلاح الدين الأيوبي
كتب اهم كتاب له
"دليل الحائرين" باللغة العربية حوالي سنة ١١٩٠ ميلادية.
للإطلاع على كل الكلمات التي اقترضتها اللغة الفرنسية من اللغة العربية،
احيلكم على كتاب عالم اللسانيات الفرنسي جون بريفو
"أسلافنا العرب" Nos ancêtres les Arabes
وكذلك كتاب وزير الثقافة والتربية الفرنسي السابق جاك لونغ
والذي يحمل عنوان" اللغة العربية، كنز فرنسا" La langue arabe, trésor de France.
لسوء حظ إيريك زمور،
ولحسن حظ الإنسانية،
الكلمات مثل الطيور،
لا تحتاج إلى جواز سفر أو تأشيرة كي تسافر.
في ما يتعلّق بمسألة اللغات،
إيريك زيمور، ليس معاديا للغة العربية فحسب
بل كذلك يعادي اللغة الإنجليزية،
في الخامس عشرمن شهر أكتوبر الماضي، كتب على حسابة بموقع تويتر:
نريد ان نحافظ
على لغتنا،
أجمل لغة،
في العالم
وأكثر لغة بيانا
نريد ان نحميها
من التأثير الأمريكي
والمغاربي
والكتابة الشاملة".
على امتداد تاريخها كانت فرنسا ارضا متعددة اللغات،
حيث ازدهرت اللهجات واللغات المحلية.
إضافة إلى أن تاريخ فرنسا ليس تاريخ اللغة الفرنسية،
فميلاد اللغة الفرنسية يعود فقط لعام 842 ميلادية
وبالتحديد لما يسمّى بقسم سترازبورغ،
فهي مزيج من اللاتنية والقلطية المختلطة بلغات جرمانية.
و تجدر الإشارة ان كل الملوك المؤسسين لفرنسا كانوا يتكلمون لغات جرمانية.
أبرزهم شارل مارتال، العزيز جدا على زيمور،
والذي اوقف الغزو العربي في مدينة بواتييه عام 732،
أو حفيده شرلمان، الذي تُوّج امبراطورا سنة ٨٠٠ ميلادية،
احد الأسماء البارزة في العصر الوسيط الأوروبي،
ومحل التجاذب بين فرنسا وألمانيا،
هذا الأخير كان شغوفا ومنبهرا بالحضارة العربية الإسلامية.
نعرف جميعا قصة الفيل الأبيض "أبو العبّاس"،
الذي قدمه الخليفة العباسي هارون الرشيد هدية ديبلوماسية لشارلمان.
بالمناسبة
جان دارك، الأيقونة الفرنسية التي استحوذ على رمزيتها اليمين المتطرّف ، لم تكن تتكلّم الفرنسية.
لا بد من الإنتظار،
إلى حدود القرن السادس عشر،
مع الملك فرنسوا الأوّل،
لتصبح اللغة الفرنسية اللغة الرسمية لفرنسا سنة 1539.
على امتداد قرون من الزمن
اللاتنية
البروتونية
الفلامانية
البورغينيونية
البكاردية
البروفانسيالية
الغاسكونية
تعايشت مع اللغة الفرنسية في جميع انحاء  فرنسا.
إريك زيمور ناطق بلغة واحدة،
نافذته الوحيدة على العالم هي اللغة الفرنسية،
وأحاديته اللغوية هي بمثابة سجن فكري طويل الأمد.
هل يعلم ان بول روبار، الرجل الذي لعب دورا رئيسيا في تاريخ قواميس اللغة الفرنسية،
الأب المؤسس لمعجمي روبار الكبير وروبار الصغير،
هو من اصحاب الأقدام السوداء،
ولد في الجزائر وعاش فيها اربعين عاما بين اللغة الفرنسية واللغة العربية والإنجليزية؟
للأسف إريك زيمور هو كذلك من أصول جزائرية،
لكنه لن يستفيد من هذا التنوع اللغوي والثقافي
لانه سيتخذ خيارا ايديولوجيا
يرفض فيه اصوله الأمازيغية المغاربية ليختار الانصهار الثقافي.
رغم ان لقبه العائلي "زيمور"
هو كلمة امازيغية وتعني "زيتون" بالعربية.
شجّعوا ابناءكم،
على تعلّم لغات أجنبية وعلى الإنفتاح على ثقافات أخرى،
إنها ثروة لا تقدّر بثمن.
شرلمان مرّة أخرى؛
يقول؛ أن تتعلّم لغة أخرى، كأن تمتلك روحا ثانية.